people often turn away from
what's possible or from actual career
choices because they don't know how
how am i going to make that a reality
gary why do you say talent comes second
to marketing for anyone trying to make
it in hollywood we can never
underestimate talent
craft is everything
but it's not everything
meaning
fundamentally hollywood is is is not a
meritocracy it's not always
the best talent that rises to the top
it's not the best
projects to get financed and and
produced and
bought
it's it's often based on who has the
best relationships
so while it's really important and i
trust that most creatives who really
want to make it in the business
are steadfast they're committed they're
studying they're writing multiple
scripts they're
they're always improving it's a it's a
process it's a learning so you're always
getting better at your craft and i
and i i don't underestimate the value of
that
so talent's important but talent that is
um not
connected up with
some form of
effective marketing idea an action plan
some kind of a road map to make sure
that you and your body of work get
noticed
it can't live in isolation talent has to
be
have a have a platform it has to be
announced to the world and marketed
and i think that too many writers
tend to ignore them the the business
side the marketing side in favor of
being very uh committed to their writing
and
and and hoping to get an agent
being in other words being passive in
the face of what in any other industry
would be considered perhaps unrealistic
so i think talent is not to be
underestimated it's it's it's it's um
it's why we're all here
but the talent needs
it needs a companion energy
so that you are
not
a best kept secret
does that have to do with uh biz dev
versus the sales mindset does that have
anything
yeah i mean
certainly i think in a way it does the
so that you know this the sales person
is is someone who's working against
quota and within a given time horizon in
there and they're looking for a specific
result which is sale their
uh their whole approach is geared toward
uh getting getting the sale
um
the the bus the biz dev person has a
totally different job definition a
different there's a different prism or
lens that they're looking through
they're looking it's like the difference
almost between in the old version
agency and management one was like
income driven commission driven and the
other was commissioner but it was really
about developing the talent longer term
mindset
in business the biz dev people
people with that responsibility set are
really looking at how do i nurture and
develop the future
business and that's not about making
sales today that's about getting to know
their business about getting to know
their customer about getting to know
their needs their wants
and how we can develop a mutually
beneficial relationship it's being
fundamentally other focused
it's not about what i need today it's
about how can i help you now and into
the future
let's let's let's create that pathway
so that i lock in a sense of loyalty and
a deeper understanding and then we can
build together
so there's an inv it's it's investment
minded as opposed to sales-minded
and i've used that analogy for
yeah certainly for creatives
like you know
be curious
be a business development person
build relationships build toward a
future
without the urgency without the anxiety
there's no stress in that there's no
need in that now it's just a gift of
genuine curiosity about the other and
not keeping yourself a secret share who
you are and what you do and why you do
it why you care what what was the first
moment when you knew
you you had to have a create you know go
down this path and be a creative
professional
christy dryling yes yes christie's a
dear friend yeah and i found her book um
accidentally uh somehow and it was
really fascinating to read especially
about her upbringing and she talked
about a poverty mindset
and i'm curious how we can all fall into
that trap and maybe not even realize it
yeah well i think it's very common look
i think that we're unfortunately
i i won't say mis-educated i'd say
under-educated i think there is you know
in our system in our culture
there are a lot of
what i consider really
essentials that we're simply not they're
not in our curriculum that we're not
taught we're not taught financial
literacy
we're not taught mindset we're not
taught success principles
um
it it it hasn't yet found its way into
the body politic that is our educational
system
um and i think that a lot of people do
fall into a poverty mindset they're you
know it's we are
um we are fed a steady diet
through the internet through the media
class
traditional media what have you
of of uh sensational stories because
that's what solves
uh and it's often fear-based
and fear is powerful medicine and most
people are not immune to it
there's very few people who can see over
that headrow and stay centered and stay
present and stay committed to their
vision and their and and what
what's theirs to do
um and we see that you know covid we see
it you know like there's a uniform
response amongst most people
to bad news and we see it all the time
um and i think it sort of degrades our
sense of
manifest destiny and our vigor and our
determination
of and belief in what's possible
applying the poverty mindset to
being active
pitching working on projects not giving
up because that poverty mindset can
permeate into other areas it's not just
financial poverty it's also sort of lack
of opportunity
the belief that you can't actually make
something happen it doesn't have to
actually mean
monetary value right
so how do we how do we get ourselves out
of that because some people could come
from
some you know a stable middle class
environment or upper middle class they
could probably still possess that
poverty mindset being told maybe you
can't make a career out of this find a
find a stable position where
you know
there's a pension very few jobs still
have pensions but
people often turn away from
what's possible or
from actual career choices because they
don't know how
how am i going to make that a reality
and my
understanding of life is it's really not
that important to understand how
what's really important is to understand
what you want
be really clear about what you want and
very clear about why you want it
and at that point the how is you know
like a collaborative effort between you
the universe and seeking out the people
who know the how
they've been down that path
and finding your mentors and finding
your collaborators finding your partners
whatever it might be
but it's if you can't go in with that
clarity that story that's really true
and clear
and persuasive about it mostly to
yourself
if you believe it others will believe it
right that's that's really persuasive
about
what it is that you want why you want it
um and what you're willing to do for it
that you're committed to it
the how just becomes the gap that needs
to be filled in with information and
relationships and that's all available
it's the determination i think a lot of
people get get stopped before they get
in the game because they don't think
it's possible they think it's too hard
they don't know how
they have all these ideas because
it's easy not to believe in yourself
it's easy to stay in your comfort zone
it's another way of saying it
um it's
it takes a certain amount of courage
to step out and do the thing
that
you fear others may judge you for
and by the way that you may fail at
right
so it's easier to be safe and stay in
your comfort zone and not take that risk
but the
but it's really not
because we only have one life
and regret is a terrible terrible thing
questioning yourself is a terrible not
believing in yourself
is
not being willing to take risk and bet
on yourself first
um
it's like chopping off an arm
you know it's just not a good way to
treat yourself
um and and if you surround yourself with
no matter what your background and i
granted it's not an equal playing field
i think all souls are created equal
people are not people's backgrounds and
experiences are so so so different and
um but i think we do have we see so many
examples of it
that kind of courage that makes people
rise above a circumstance say i'm so
committed to this
and no matter what my experience or what
my background i am going to find the
people who are more successful who are
in the
direction i want to move in and i'm
going to go there i'm going to
make them my
target and my compatriots and what have
you my mentors
i think it just you know most people
aren't natural born leaders and they
don't necessarily
i read a book years and years ago called
the slight edge jeff holson i think is
the author
and in that book there was really it's
he talks about habits but
the thing that makes it come to mind is
there's a moment in the book when he
talks about a sociological study that
was done that determined
that by the age of five which i is what
first grade
that by the age of five a child has on
average heard the word no
40 000 times and he's hurt that same
child's heard the word yes 8 000 times
so literally five times the gravity
holding that belief system that human
being down
as there is a yes energy uplifting or
elevating or thinking oh
these things are more possible for me
and
um
that really stuck obviously it stayed
with me i read that book years and years
ago
because i thought my god the math of
that is really a heavy weight
so i think the one of the keys is surren
really take yourself out of your
the other comfort zone is
don't necessarily settle
for those who are your current tribe or
community or the people you hang with
right
like really make a decision that you're
gonna get with people who are the doers
not the dreamers with the people who
will believe in you not the ones who
will judge you
like really consciously say
i deserve better
and i don't want to say it's like fake
until you make it because i actually
think everyone deserves it but if you're
willing to go after what you think you
can grow into what you deserve increase
your capacity
find the people who are going to say
yeah
we support you we not only don't judge
you we encourage you